hey guys it's februari 27th I'm chastity
I'm with you all week for GDC but more
importantly it's pokemons birthday and
we're having the party the Pokemon
franchise turns 21 today so
congratulations squirtle you're old
enough to drink now someone get this boy
a cocktail februari 27th is pokemon day
the original games came out in japan on
februari 27th 1996 making the franchise
21 years old this year fans can expect a
number of events as well to mark the
latest anniversary of the celebrated and
perpetually popular franchise one of the
biggest events is happening in Pokemon
go now until march sixth a special
version of Pikachu who's wearing a
festive party hat will appear in the
world developer niantic said in a blog
post these special pikachu will keep
their party hats forever but they can
only be found during this limited time
celebration so make sure to keep an eye
out for them as you explore other
Pokemon Day celebrations include the
launch of a new gallery figures
collection featuring toys for EV meu
Magikarp and of course Pikachu what's
more a new Pikachu yellow edition new
Nintendo 3ds XL is now available for two
hundred dollars while gamestop is giving
up bottle caps for Pokemon Sun and
Pokemon moon right now the Pokemon
Trading Card Game online and the Pokemon
shuffle app are celebrating as well with
new bonuses available now lastly the
pokemon company is holding an all day
celebration on twitch today featuring
footage from the pokemon world
championships and more next up
middle-earth shadow of war has been
confirmed and it's got an awesome
trailer after yesterday's leaked Warner
Brothers today officially announced a
follow-up to middle-earth shadow of
Mordor the new game is titled shadow of
war the announcement trailer is a CG
video with the first gameplay slated to
arrive on March 8th like shadow of
Mordor shadow war is developed by
monolith productions talion and
celebrant bore returned from the first
game they must quote go behind enemy
lines to forge an army and turn all of
Mordor Against the Dark Lord Sauron
shadow war is set between the events of
The Hobbit and The Lord of the Rings the
first games praised nemesis system also
returns shadow of wars updated
the system features an element called
followers these are characters that will
add entirely new stories of loyalty
betrayal and revenge overall model is
promising quote a richer more personal
and expansion world for shadow of war
players can expect to see epic heroes
and villains as well as iconic locations
original enemy types even more
personalities and a new cast of
characters with untold stories shadow of
war will be available on playstation 4
xbox one and pc in its own statement
microsoft confirmed that shadow war will
be an Xbox play anywhere title for Xbox
one and Windows 10 additionally
microsoft announced that shadow war will
be available on project scorpio this
holiday the game will also be available
on ps4 Pro shadow war launches on August
22nd in North America and August 25th in
Europe and finally minecraft sales have
reached 121 million copies that's a lot
I still don't get it the minecraft
franchise continues to soar microsoft
announced today that the series has
passed 121 million copies sold and 55
million unique players this is the first
official sales and engagement update
since june when microsoft confirmed 100
million sales and 40 million unique
monthly players microsoft celebrated the
new minecraft milestones today some
animated gifts that speak to the
enormity of the sandbox game as it
relates to sales and monthly users
microsoft acquired the minecraft
franchise and developer mojang in 2014 4
2.5 billion dollars series creator
markus notch Persson held a 70-percent
sheraton mojang and would go on to leave
the company after the buyout minecraft
is available on PC and all major
consoles as well as smartphones we've
got lots of cool new stuff for you to
check out on gamespot so check out
reboot it's new and it went up yesterday
with the first episode about resident
evil 7 and the revival of the horror
survival genre so check it out and
celebrate Pokemon all day thank you see
you tomorrow